[Música]
continuamos con nuestro segundo invitado
del día el pasado lunes 18 de octubre se
cumplieron en chile- dos años del
estallido social que derivó en una
constituyente para así escribir su nueva
carta magna la finalidad de estas
manifestaciones fueron establecer bases
más justas y diversas en ese país
sudamericano estos dos años se
celebraron en un periodo de tensión y
también de baja aprobación del
presidente sebastián piñera investigado
además tras la divulgación de los
famosos papeles de pandora para ello
quiero saludar en este momento jaime
basales el vicepresidente de la
convención constitucional constituyente
por el distrito 7 también doctor en
derecho constitucional profesor titular
de la universidad de valparaíso gracias
jaime por estar con nosotros en directo
américa buen día para ti feliz viernes
le pregunto cómo comenzó entonces a
redactarse esta nueva constitución en
chile
hola muy buenos días bueno antes que
todo muchas gracias por el contacto pero
el interés es lo que estaba pasando en
nuestro país estamos viendo procesos de
transformación políticas sean y cultural
muy importante muy significativo y
efectivamente se han cumplido
dos años ya desde desde el inicio de la
revuelta social en octubre del 2019
estamos prontos al primer aniversario
del plebiscito del 25 de octubre del
2020 que permitió verdad abrir también
este proceso constituyente y las
elecciones que se realizaron en mayo en
2021 estamos muy contentos muy
esperanzados con lo que viene en estos
momentos estamos
realizando los discursos de apertura de
los debates constituyentes por parte de
cada uno de las y los constituyentes y
en medio de una expectativa muy
importante
de estabilidad política pero también de
justicia social y de transformación de
instituciones que puedan es perspectiva
mente al servicio de interés general
jaime también usted dijo que esto se
estaba realizando no en una nueva
práctica política y si se construye con
un ánimo colaborativo que quiere es
decir con este ánimo colaborativo y cuál
es esta nueva práctica política
ese es un elemento bien bien interesante
y yo creo que hemos logrado ver
a lo largo el despliegue institucional
de la convención constitucional en la
forma en la que la presidenta loncón y
yo como vicepresidente hemos logrado
armar un equipo de trabajo bastante
horizontal donde no hay una cabeza única
no hay una jefatura sino que hay un
equipo que busca empujar los procesos
institucionales necesarios para que la
convención constitucional pueda cumplir
con su cometido
y esa ha sido una forma de trabajo y de
alguna manera ha irradiado a la
convención constitucional en su conjunto
forzando y creo yo generando las
condiciones para que el trabajo de las y
los constituyentes
sea realizado desde las prácticas
políticas desde el diálogo desde la
construcción progresiva de acuerdos
y siempre desde la clave desde dos o
tres grandes claves que dan forma a
asambleas constituyentes que son la
paridad de género entre hombres y
mujeres la presencia de escaños
reservados de los pueblos originarios y
la representación de nuevas formas de
organización política distinta de los
partidos como ha sido la presencia de
independientes y de movimientos sociales
eso ha generado formas de diálogo
político entre los distintos sectores
que tienen representación constituyente
muy distintas a las formas que hemos
visto hasta ahora en el congreso
nacional en el pueblo nativo y eso a mi
juicio se debe precisamente a que hay
formas de representación política hay
forma de representación social que han
logrado y al espacio institucional de
representación
protagonizando prácticas políticas
distintas y tanto la presidenta como yo
así como toda la mesa directiva que la
componen nueve personas en total hemos
estado a la disposición y el service
y si no bueno jaime estamos perdiendo un
poco de comunicación con ustedes estamos
conversando en este momento con este
segundo invitado al día en jaime vas a
vicepresidente de la convención
constitucional de chile estaba hablando
pues por supuesto de que esta es una
primera constitución en el mundo que se
hace con paridad de género también allí
están incluidos los indígenas mapuche
pues un pueblo que ha sido ellos dicen
es segregado por muchísimos años en ese
país y que finalmente están siendo
representados en estas reuniones que
comenzaron esta semana para escribir
esta nueva carta magna de chile que como
también estábamos comentando ya hace dos
años el 18 de octubre de hace dos años
inició este estallido social en chile
para tratar de buscar un país más justo
sentar unas bases más justas en ese país
y esto derivó no en el plebiscito
constituyente que fue aprobado que fue
votado por los chilenos en mayoría para
poder así entonces escribir y una nueva
carta magna la presidenta incluso de
este órgano es la académica y activista
mapuche como lo estaba bien comentando
jaime el y salón con pues quede claro
que por primera vez los pueblos
originarios de chile están representados
en esto jaime estaba haciendo más o
menos un resumen de nuestra conversación
porque se nos cayó la conversación pero
ya lo tenemos de nuevo con usted
estábamos hablando no de estos pueblos
originarios de muchas personas incluidas
de ámbitos diferentes de la sociedad
también políticamente ha sido difícil
buscar un consenso o al revés si ha sido
gracias a esta riqueza no a esta
diversidad de encontrar puntos en común
para poder escribir esta nueva
constitución que qué problema le ve a
esto o si no es una una ayuda sea cómo
lo ve
yo creo que una de las grandes de los
grandes cambios de las grandes
innovaciones que representa esta
asamblea constituyente es que hay una
pluralidad de voces hay una diversidad
de voces que están presentes y
representadas en la convención
constitucional quien permitió que el
diálogo político en la sociedad sea
también distinto
y yo me atrevería a decir que
estamos viendo como desde la diversidad
desde la diferencia estamos generando
las condiciones para que todos
aprendamos a vivir en condiciones de
igualdad y reconociéndolos como iguales
pero también recordación menos como
diferente es verdad que siendo parte de
un pueblo que comparte un proyecto
venido a un proyecto de futuro pero
siendo parte también de pueblos que
conviven en la complejidad y la
pluralidad de esa de ese proyecto yo
creo que esa diversidad y ha enriquecido
mucho el debate verdad mucho mucho mucho
más de lo que ha ocurrido por ejemplo
con los procesos legislativos en los
últimos 30 años y ha mejorado las
condiciones de la deliberación porque
precisamente porque enriquece las
perspectivas que concurren en él en el
diálogo